the former fast minister of scotland
alex salmond once led the country in an
independence referendum
under the leadership of nicolas sturgeon
his protege there's a new bid for
scotland to break away from the uk but
she faces pressure from her former boss
who is demanding more action on the
plans earlier i spoke to mr salmond
about his role in scottish politics
since leaving office and the controversy
around him mr simon thanks for joining
us on the show today i'm actually as you
know i'm in brussels uh you're in london
i'm here because i was talking to maris
sekovich today about some of the
consequences of the uk leaving the
european union a union it's been in for
nearly 50 years this week your successor
first minister nicholas sturgeon
launched plans for that second
independence referendum what did you
think of her proposals
well i mean apart from the comparison
with other countries which is a
perfectly fair thing to do because it's
right and proper to make the point that
other small european countries are doing
much better than the uk is doing it
economically there wasn't really much
proposals beyond that but of course
we're promised
a series of papers to come i suppose
like many people in the national
movement i'm just i'm just
pleased that the starting gun has
eventually been fired because we've been
waiting on it for some considerable time
and do you think she's the right person
to lead this campaign and would you
share a platform with her
well yes the second part of your
question in terms of being the right
person she's the inevitable person to
lead the campaign she's the head of the
scottish government the scottish
government have a a prime role in the
independence referendum i i don't think
we should have the the only role
incidentally i think it's really really
important that our voices from out with
government
who are proclaiming independence i asked
you partly because obviously there's
kind of quite a lot of personal
animosity between the two of you
at the moment or is that now being
cleared up i've been part of a personal
difference to between myself and
nicholas i mean they are insignificant
compared to the the national cause of
scotland becoming independent which i
and nicholas sturgeon have devoted to
our lives so
i don't think you would find
any personal difficulties
coming in the way of something which is
much bigger much greater than any two
individuals i just want to ask you about
what you think brexit has done to this
possible solution for scotland nicholas
sturgeon has made it clear she still
wants to join the european union and the
single market that's what you once
wanted i think uh but brexit's changed
your mind is that right
well i've changed minded in the sense
that i think it'd be a better option for
scotland at least initially but perhaps
in the long term to be in the european
free trade association and the
four-member
association
there are many advantages of that but i
think the prime advantage is well it
takes perhaps five years
to join the european union uh whereas
after what takes about three months to
join having the security of after
membership strikes me as a very good
idea indeed then you can decide over the
longer term if whether the people of
scotland want to go in for the
for the european union brexit you would
acknowledge has complicated the picture
a bit for scotland would you would you
agree with that i mean nicolas sturgeon
got into quite a lot of hot water or
difficulties uh in that press conference
when people repeatedly asking her about
what we're seeing now in northern
ireland and the read across for scotland
and is there going to be a hard border
between scotland and england that that's
a massive problem isn't it i mean scots
might want to be independent they might
not want a hard border if you've you've
said complication difficulties and hard
border in the same question
i mean i think part of the difficulties
think about at the press conference was
they haven't published their proposals
on europe yet
if we're taking the northern irish
example what the border non-island has
meant with their
total access to the single market has
been a prosperity for northern ireland
in relative terms at least for the first
time in recorded economic statistics in
northern ireland as a top of the table
in terms of the nations and regions of
the united kingdom
in this interview we're not we're not
solving the problems of northern ireland
but we're looking to know an irish
example to see what it tells us about
scotland and what it tells us and you
wouldn't nobody would describe nobody
serious personally you know perhaps the
union that's pressed in scotland might
describe that minister of border and the
irish sea is a hard border do you accept
though that um there would be checks on
goods between england and scotland or
you think there's a way to avoid that
because
well the center would be checks at the
border i mean the the the maximum you'd
have certainly on an after proposal
the two countries a point of saw some
point of origin now
yes
that's one of the that's one of the
consequences now there are advantages of
that the primary advantage would be that
you'd have full access to a single
market 500 million people so you know
there are pros and cons swings and
roundabouts all i'm pointing out to you
is no amount in economic terms if we
leave to one side the politics yes the
pros have been much greater than the
cons how likely do you think there will
be a referendum before the next general
election then well i mean i i take the
scottish government as word i mean it's
a no ifs no buts uh commitment now that
there's going to be a referendum by
october of next year so the national
movement scotland are looking forward to
taking part in that referendum you could
see a scenario where the where hollywood
legislate for a referendum but they
don't hold a referendum could you see
that as a possibility i see many
scenarios but the first thing to do is
to ask for it to let boris johnson deny
it to let him deny the will of the
scottish parliament and then take effect
of political election to change his mind
as i say my view is that boris johnson
is not a strong political figure i think
you know
it's an open question as if he'll even
be prime minister by the autumn
and therefore this seems to me a very
good time to exert
political and democratic pressure you
were taken to court in 2020 on a series
of sexual assault charges you were
acquitted of all of those charges
um and at the time some of your allies
suggested you'd been a victim of a witch
hunt within the scottish national party
you then went on
with allegations that there was a
conspiracy against you designed to cause
your downfall and even imprisonment
that was unproven we had the hollyrood
inquiry and the investigation by james
hamilton
both strongly criticized nicolas
sturgeon but they didn't say there was
an organized conspiracy
it was a torrid time have you come to
terms with all of that put it behind you
is that saga now over
well certainly it's not going to get in
the way of an independence campaign
i mean there's a police investigation
ongoing into illegal leaks of material
from the scottish government there's
also a clown investigation or a crown
review of possible perjury
at the high court trial and now these
things must be allowed to take the
course they're in the hands of the
police and
the crown office and obviously i've
given
evidence to both of these because i
would like to see them come to a
conclusion has it politically damaged
you know the reason i ask is that
nicholas sturgeon uh said uh from her
own conversations with you and i'm going
to quote her she said his behavior was
inappropriate and she said she'd search
your testimony for signs of reflection
and recognition of your behavior but
there was not a single word to
acknowledge that do you acknowledge that
your behavior towards women
at times was was inappropriate
i'm not going to go over what was well
gone over well-trod material beth that's
in the hands of a police investigation
in the hands of the crown officer
nothing i'm going to say is going to
enter i hear in these ongoing no um this
is really important before there's a
police investigation into criminal leaks
from within the scottish government
there's a crown of investigation to
possible perjury at the trial i am not
going to say anything that cuts across
these investigations clearly they're not
investigations into me
but other people are entitled to the
same natural justice as i am and
therefore i'm not going to follow you
down this road but i will not
is answering any questions you wish on
the independence campaign which i'm
delighted to participate i need to ask
you this in light of
uh what's happening in ukraine you only
gave up your russia today show in
february you started doing it in 2017.
that was after years of reprimands
towards the channel from ofcon high
profile resignations from employees sick
of being made to give up to give out the
kremlin line yet you took that job why
and now in light of what's happened
subsequently do you regret that do you
think again that has politically
tarnished you
well beth they in terms of reprimands by
ofcom
sky television is many many more than
than
rt managed incidentally
that's just the fact until at least the
the last you know 17 in a day which was
done in march in terms of my program i
total editorial independence and nobody
i think would ever suggest that that
program was anything other than fair
and balanced and gave everybody a chance
to speak and put forward the point of
view
and there was no interference in that
program not even you know for example
when i interviewed peter patchell about
his experience and
in campaigning for for gay rights during
the world cup nobody said boo to it from
rt obviously i suspended the program and
then made that permanent uh on the
russian invasion of ukraine because i
thought it was impossible to conduct a
common affairs program in a war time
environment but in terms of my
experience for rt as a broadcaster i had
no complaints or difficulties in terms
of russia's foreign policy i'm afraid my
thoughts on that are that
illegal invasions of other countries
never work but then of course my
consistency in opposing illegal
invasions is rather better than other
politicians i mean i've opposed the
legal invasions of countries regardless
of who was doing the invading very few
people can say that you're famously a
betting man what are the odds of an
independent scotland in your lifetime oh
heavy odds on i mean the royal ascots on
today uh even without have managed to
the queen unfortunately but the royal
ascots on today i think if
independence in my lifetime was a was a
runner that would be heavy odds on in
the gold cup
okay alex simon thanks so much uh for
talking to me i appreciate your time not
at all thank you and this time